uh president biden's throne open the
border but somehow dha secretary get
this
alejandro mayorkas now telling ice
agents he's actually an immigration
hardliner
during a virtual town hall last week
with ice personnel
majorcas reportedly said this quote i'm
100 opposed to the abolition of ice
i think we need to strengthen our
policies and practices and communicate
more effectively
with what we what we do and why we do it
he also took on sanctuary cities
who won't work with ice joining us now
is tom homan former acting ice director
is your head spinning tom
yeah my head's been but you know i don't
believe in what he says like he's the
same person that says
the borders closed the border secured
there's not a crisis we all know
differently
so you know actually speak louder and
worse just the sanctuary cities issue
brian three weeks ago the administration
dropped the lawsuit that we had against
sanctuary cities
so to to drop the lawsuit try to hold
sanctuary cities
accountable to drop that lawsuit then
all of a sudden say well
we're going to fight sanctuary cities
look they're speaking on both sides of
mouth actions speak louder than words
they say that there's gaps in the wall
the roads that were made are now being
used by smugglers
you guys made the wall to help move uh
in and out quickly
along with technology and now you the
deputy when you knew me was deputy
secretary but now he's saying that maybe
we'll fill those gaps in the wall that
was in the washington times today
i kind of believe him because he's
responsible the vice president is not
showing up to take over
the president doesn't know how to get
there so he knows at one point
it's it's fell into his lap he can't
keep on giving us
the heisman as a country do you expect
him to grab some pieces of wall and put
it up
i hope he does because it'd be the right
thing to do because walt's work
every place that built a wall illegal
immigration has declined illegal drug
falls declined
walls save lives and waltz will help
with with the current crisis on the
border
but this is the same person who said
that the reason they changed ice
priorities
talking about ice they took 90 percent
of their priorities away so 90 percent
of the criminal aliens they arrested
last year they can't arrest that this
year
because they're no longer on the table
right and they said he said in this
the same meeting and it had to be done
because of lack of resources limited
resources
let me be clear there's no lack of
resources in fy 12
ice removed 409 000 arrested and removed
409 000
they're on track this year to remove 65
000
so they're doing 16th of the work
i mean 65 000 compared to 409 000
they had 52 000 people in detention now
they got 14 000
ice officers have nothing to do they're
sitting around so don't say there's lack
resources
you have crippled them there are plenty
of ice officers willing and able to go
out and arrest criminal aliens if you
would let them
tom what did you see real quick at the
border that was different this time than
any other time when you were served
because you've been down there a couple
of times now
because i talked to a lot of barbecue
agents and their american patriots and
and every one of them i talked to has
lost total respect on our president
our commander-in-chief because he fails
to recognize that this is a crisis it
was preventable
his transition team was brief this was
happened they did it anyways
and he knew what he was doing he made
all his promises during the campaign he
knew this would cause the surge
they lost respect in the secretary who
refuses to call this a crisis
saying it's secure and it's close
because these border patrols are working
24 7.
they're getting sick they're working
vast amounts of overtime they're taking
sicknesses home their own family
in the administration keeps saying with
this policy it's it's a giving policy
you know let me tell you something the
only kindness i saw on the border was
the board's relations the way they
treated these children and families
they treat them with utmost respect and
dignity and that's the only compassion i
saw
was borbutil agents the men on the front
line showing compassion
this administration's open borders
policies show no compassion
because 30 what was the 18 000 families
have chosen to put their kids in the
arms of criminal cartels to enter this
country illegally that is not compassion
that is dangerous and it's just stupid
it's just to say that loving parents
send their kids to the border which the
secretary said
wrong loving parents don't put their
kids in the arms of criminal cartels
they don't there's no doubt about it and
even though we have a big heart for the
kids
i have no uh i have no patience for the
parents uh tom holman if people want to
solve the crisis
you'll pick up the phone if you call and
you'll do it for free and you've been
there and you know how to beat it in
2021 like you've done in years past
tom thanks so much thanks for having me
brian